today's topic stephen crowder all right
so if you aren't aware
recently i believe joe biden passed a
form of stimulus that
is going to encourage um the farming
industry as well as a lot of black
farmers a lot of the money is going to
black farmers and the reason for that is
because in the past there's been a
tremendous amount of discrimination
against black farmers in terms of loans
and things like that
so that's what's happening now in order
to rectify the mistakes that they've
made before
steven crowder heard about this joe
former vice president joe biden
of course his america rescue plan
includes
farmer reparations now what does that
mean it means and i don't know where you
find
this many farmers of color uh
but they did and 5.2 billion are being
allocated exclusively
if you aren't aware that black people
farm it's a very common thing especially
if you go to the south
you don't know your story you don't know
your history that's just plain
stereotypes and ignorance but carry-ons
for colored farmers farmers of color
farmers of color roll the tape we begin
today's show looking at a major
provision in president biden's 1.9
trillion dollar covid relief bill
that aims to address decades of
discrimination against black
hispanic native american and asian
american farmers
who've historically been excluded from
government agricultural programs
the american rescue plan sets aside 10.4
billion
for agriculture support and allocates
about half the funds to farmers of color
who are quote subjected to racial or
ethnic prejudice because of their
identity as members of a group
unquote the u.s commission on civil
rights confirmed as long ago as 1965
the u.s department of agriculture
discriminated against black farmers
but little was done to address 100 years
ago
yeah 100 years ago 1965 is not a hundred
years ago
are you an idiot is crowder surrounded
by some of the dumbest people ever
wow that's like 60 years my friend it's
like do you not know how to count
it's it's less than 60 years you know
when we we you saw that that video we
did that video
all the riots and stuff like that and i
was like seven crowding is being
disingenuous what you said was
woefully and willfully ignorant and now
that's what it is
i don't know he doesn't know his
american history or something like that
or whatever
he's got people around him who do the
research for them the fact that nobody
could just do a quick google search
most happy about the new policy these
people so yeah
i'm gonna buy a plow man i'm gonna plant
that corn
go get a giant there barack obama i'm
the president of plowing that ass
you crowder's gonna crowd her these guys
are so cringy
these guys are unbelievably cringing and
you know their
undertones are so apparent it's crazy to
me might as well just put on blackface
you might as well
might as well honestly there's kind of
like crazy characters that you're trying
to drive as you're doing these
this is just cringey to me this week the
mystical
age-old culture of china
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you you're good y'all you go yo you
good
you kept that at the end yeah you good
that was good it's just jokes guys okay
wow cool story you guys think that's
humor if you think that's trying to be
funny
cool story you can't use a veil of humor
to do say this kind of stuff and always
be like it's just comedy
we know the difference and most smart
people know the difference okay wow
right um i can't just you know put on
like you know
say like i thought the last thing they
would want to do was be farmers wasn't
that a big problem yeah
isn't that why arsenio hall called
himself the urban man's johnny carson
i think so yeah i don't know i don't
know people are people lining up
out in the middle of cornfield iowa for
new dunks
how would you prove this by the way like
how would you prove that you've been
discriminated
it's easy you guys this has been settled
in court this is not hearsay
not only has the department admitted to
these practices in the past but they've
had to settle in court
as a result of being brought to court
and it's the largest settlement
post-civil rights movement
uh in regards to this matter it's like
so much money was allocated this is like
in the 90s that this happened
this settlement to handle this and you
guys have to understand the farming
industry is like a bunch of subsidies
it's a bunch of loan programs because
farming is not profitable enough on its
face
so the government constantly has to
subsidize it and do this so that they
can compete with the global market
and still provide food to americans and
people all over the world right so the
government has to put money into that
when you say i'm not going to give money
to black farmers
or i'm not going to give money to you
know people of color who farm
you are essentially killing them out of
the market when white farmers are
getting these subsidies they're getting
all this money
but then we're we're not that causes an
imbalance in the market
this is not hearsay you can google
google these verifiable facts that's not
an opinion either
you know how could you even prove that
redlining happened easy there's cases
that have admitted
that have showcased this my problem
isn't that they have these opinions is
that these
they can just google this stuff and find
this information how would you prove
that you've been discriminated you don't
have to you just well i didn't get that
loan sir you had no credit well that
should not have stopped me from getting
the loan
i planted a hennessey tree yeah you know
listen
if i got big lips and the large ears and
a wide nose and i suck in all the oxygen
because i'm like a monkey like they
might as well just said that it's pretty
much what they're saying
a henny sea tree really you know and
they're like how could you prove you're
discriminating against is that what you
think
these guys are using all the worst
character tricks to try to do rewrite
history and almost discount the
suffering that real people have gone
through
to see like you guys didn't even go
through anything that's what he's been
through and people
you should debate crowder why would i
debate someone like that this man is
disingenuous i don't mind people
who would have a different opinion but
at least are honest about the facts this
man is a
is a blatant liar he panders to his
crowd because they like hearing this
stuff because it never
it never conflicts with their worldview
he's he's so
apparently disingenuous with this stuff
i'll link in the description read this
this is not my opinion this is the us
government
this is i think the department of
agriculture who've admitted this
so when they're admitting culpability
how are you therefore afterwards coming
out be like well how can you prove that
they've admitted it
you want us to to talk or to you know
argue with this person when you know
this is going to be the same ammo that's
going to happen it's not even based on
facts
whenever you fight with a pig in the mud
at some point you have to realize that
the pig
enjoys it and that's what's going to
happen he's going to just throw
things out there that makes no sense and
we're going to try to prove it
and it has something to do he enjoys
that so there's no point arguing
but it's not growing well well
technically it did grow
but that they next hope i put it on the
ground i planted a vsop
exo treat i'm getting into niche
esoteric cognac human mother
don't white people just go to their
neighborhoods and build urban farms and
ruin their
yeah isn't that what's how it works
detroit turns out the uh the the the
soil content there's a high level of
meth crazy
well wow i didn't know that in teeth
just
littered everywhere i don't know how
people watch these guys
the amount of pandering that happens on
these people's platforms it's just
fascinating to watch
and you know there has to be an argument
to be made like there's a financial
incentive to lean into a certain
direction because it benefits you
and it appeases your crowd it's very
profitable
the amount of money that was offered to
us to say certain things crazy you
wouldn't believe
oh i just crazy so when i watch this
stuff i'm like i'm not surprised
these people are clearly liars they're
clearly being disingenuous with some of
the stuff that they're saying
they know it's patently false a simple
google search proves this
they have researchers on deck you know
they do find all kinds of justifications
for terrible things that are happening
well this person felt this type of way
and you can imagine that if you look at
all the facts
but then here they come in with such
ignorance right
and then they use these kind of like
stereotypical character characters
right pretty much doing blackface it is
it's blackface is not the blackface
that's what it is
and they're laughing about it and it's
just like okay that's how you roll it's
cool
i don't get mad i don't get upset i just
peep game and i'm like i know how it
and you're talking to somebody who's
like they featured one of my videos on
their
on their website and i cringed so hard
because i'm like i don't even want to be
associated with you guys
but you know um it's profitable so get
your money i guess
but for those of you who want to find
objective
like objective facts that are relevant
to public discourse like i said i'll put
in the description below you can read up
on these settlements you can read up on
the statements
but don't look at all this stuff and
just be like oh my god
they're getting handouts the whole
farming industry is a bunch of handouts
it's all subsidies that's how it
functions
uh yeah that's uh pretty much most of my
thoughts on the matter
i think you pretty much covered it i
just have nothing to say about this
because there's nothing to say about
this you know i'll be like
no hennessy tree guys if you don't think
this man
doesn't have some bad ideas you're being
disingenuous at best disingenuous
at best all right that's all i'm gonna
say about crowder
uh absolute garbage i can't stand this
content
anyways that's just my thoughts on the
matter yeah great i ain't gonna say
something more what do you guys think in
the comments below
[Music]
foreign oh